Concrete vs Cement
Have you ever wondered what the difference
is between cement and concrete?
Well, wonder no more.
In general terms, the word cement refers to
any kind of binder that tightly holds other
materials together.
Concrete, on the other hand, is a mixture
of materials like sand, gravel, and small
rocks combined with any type of cement and
water.
The concoction is then allowed to dry and
harden.
Basically, concrete is the stone-like structure
formed after cement and other materials are
mixed together.
The cement is just a part of the recipe.
Cement has been used as a binder of materiel
for millenia.
No one knows for sure who first came up with
the idea to use a cement substance to bind
materials together to make concrete, bricks,
and other building materials.
The process can be traced back to Ancient
Macedonia, but was more widely popularized
during the Roman Empire.
Early forms of cement used things like lime
and pozzolana, a type of volcanic ash.
The Romans were able to produce massive structures
like the Pantheon and the Roman aqueducts
using this formula.
Currently, cement comes in two forms: Hydraulic
and Non-Hydraulic.
Hydraulic cement refers to any cement that
uses water to begin a chemical reaction that
hardens the mixture and, when fully formed,
creates a water resistant product.
This reaction is independent of the water
content of the mixture so allows for the material
to harden even underwater.
This makes it a very versatile construction
material.
Most all cements used today are hydraulic
cements.
Non-hydraulic cement uses materials that do
not harden when exposed to water.
While this type is much cheaper than hydraulic
cement, the problems of long drying times,
combined with the inability to use it in wet
environments makes it a poor choice in most
applications.
The most common type of modern cement is portland
cement (sometimes referred to as OPC for “Ordinary
Portland Cement”).
This type of cement is typically made by grinding
small rock-like bits of sintered limestone
and aluminosilicate minerals into a very fine
powder.
Its fast drying times combined with its higher
compression strength compared to other cements,
makes it a great choice for use in concrete,
mortar, grout, and stucco.
Concrete is a mixture of cement, water, and
aggregates.
Aggregates make up approximately 60-75% of
the mixture and cement and water make up the
rest.
Aggregates are usually inert course materials
like gravel, crushed stone, sand, or recycled
concrete.
The type of aggregate selected depends on
the application of the concrete.
Given that concrete starts out as a semi-liquid,
has great weather proof properties, and high
strength, its applications for use in construction
are almost endless.
The benefits of concrete include its durability,
fire-resistance, low maintenance, energy efficiency
and environmental friendliness.
In fact, concrete is the most widely used
man made material on earth.
From all this, it’s easy to see why some
people would use the terms cement and concrete
interchangeably.
One is a main ingredient in the other.
Bonus Facts:
• “Concrete” comes from the word “Concretus”
which is Latin for “compact or condensed”.
• On March 21, 2011 Ed Byrne broke 55 concrete
blocks with his bare hands in 4.86 seconds,
setting a new world record.
The previous record for this same amount of
blocks was 17.49 seconds.
• The Three Gorges Dam in China is the largest
concrete structure in the world.
It contains 27.2 million cubic meters of concrete.
The previous record was held by the Grand
Coulee Dam in Washington State, at 9 million
cubic meters of concrete, which is enough
to build an 8 foot wide sidewalk around the
equator of
the Earth.